hamilton are happy because the musical
is coming back to the smith center and
that is just one of many great plays on
tap for next season here to talk about
it is our friend who actually has one of
the venues inside the smith center named
after him myron martin thanks so much
for coming today of course kendall of
course yeah how exciting is it that we
get to bring hamilton back to los
angeles i saw it last time it was here
and it was phenomenal and this lineup we
were talking beforehand
you always have great lineups as you do
currently running but this next season
which is great because it's 10 years and
we'll talk about that in a second is
phenomenal not only hamilton but what
are some of the others that people are
really going to be excited well to kill
a mockingbird is
the best play i've seen on broadway in
my memory i mean
extraordinary writing beautifully done
and for a change we're getting a
straight play like
mockingbird coming to las vegas the fact
that it's coming to the smith center
means an awful lot to me and i know it
will sell out very quickly is this the
first time you've had a non-musical it's
not the first time
but it's the first time that we've had
the most successful play ever to appear
on broadway
at the smithsonian this one you say was
tweaked by aaron sorkin who's a
brilliant writer a brilliant writer
brilliant producer i mean he put his
touches on it and it's just perfection
that's it's such a good lineup i'm so
looking forward to it it has been 10
years is that hard to believe uh some
days it's impossible to believe because
it's like we just opened yeah other days
it feels like we've always been here
yeah right it just feels like a like a
comfortable pair of shoes and people
love coming here and the fact that we're
reopened after kovac yes means an awful
lot and and to celebrate 10 years of of
each and every year being on pole star's
list of top theaters in the world in
fact making the top 10 each and every
year
means an awful lot deservedly so i i've
had the opportunity to go to different
theaters and this truly is one of the
most beautiful i've ever been in and
it's something to be proud of as las
vegas and certainly something for you to
be proud of since you are the one of the
originators of this well listen i i have
had a blast and the fact that we get to
talk about shows like moulin rouge and
and and mean girls coming to las vegas
as a part of this uh the series the fact
that we've got something for everyone
coming to the smith center whether it's
broadway music theater dance there
really is something for everybody so i
encourage people to go to the smith
center website march is our 10th
anniversary month and instead of having
one big show we're having a lot of big
shows that's great and you get to pick
your favorites and come down and and
enjoy the experience but celebrate the
10th anniversary with us at the same
time this really has changed the the art
culture i think in las vegas before the
smith center las vegas was not
necessarily known for such things i mean
there were pockets that people knew
about but on the whole now it's renowned
and shows like to kill a mockingbird
come to the smith center well it's the
truth i mean we are part of the first
national tour we'll get the first
national tour of six
this new telling of the six wives of
henry viii in a really upbeat and kind
of
fun new way that's coming
there's just so many amazing things
coming to the smith center and you're
right it's because we set the tone from
the beginning
and we created something that is
unmatched around the country every show
wants to come to las vegas now and it
has been a minute since i've seen you so
congratulations on myron's one of the
venues named after you which is it's so
great and so appropriate well listen i
fought hard to build that that room
with
no idea that it would ever be named for
me i'm still a little embarrassed by it
although i like it yeah
but i love it when all of my friends the
the greatest local musicians perform
there yeah that makes me feel really
good well it's such a great venue all of
it and congratulations for all the
success at the smith center and the
upcoming 10th season
myron thanks a lot for more information
you can visit smithcenter.com and check
out the lineup for next year and the big
shows in march